hey guys dr. Berg here in this video we're going
to talk about what is the absolute best diet for
swollen feet and ankles okay now the first thing
you need to know is if you have this condition you
have to realize it so it's a major problem it's
not a little thing and lot of times people kind
of brush it off as well use have food retention
go to the doctor get lasix or a diuretic and push
the fluid out no you need to really realize that
it's a major problem either with the liver or the
kidney or the heart and you really need to take a
systemic approach or a whole body approach because
what's happening in your ankles is happening in
other places too and there's several mechanisms
like for example you can have an imbalance with
electrolytes okay but that's more unlikely because
when you have like either pitting edema you're
pressing in there it's usually the organ that
is failing so it's usually more of a low protein
in the blood now it's not just a matter of eating
more protein to get more protein or blood so you
can push the fluid out that's not going to work
because really the liver and the kidney are not
allowing the production of the right types of
protein like your liver takes from the blood amino
acids and makes a certain protein called albumin
which goes in the blood and then it actually helps
in the transmission of fluid to the blood and when
you don't when this conversion doesn't happen
because the liver is damaged then you get all
this this low protein albumin in the blood and
then the fluid kind of goes out of the blood
alright so the protein keeps the fluid in the
blood you know correctly so here's what you have
to do as a foundation you need to get the diet
corrected and it starts with vegetables that is
the first thing you need to start including if
you're doing like a cup of vegetables that are
steamed or cooked you're never going to get well
you're going to have to do large quantities of
raw salads and vegetables we're not talking about
romaine or sorry iceberg lettuce I'm talking about
spinach kale high-quality vegetables because this
has a lot of great things enzymes and minerals to
help push the fluid out and also make you
feel better but also people do like apple
cider vinegar which is a great thing sometimes
they'll do certain fruit juices like watermelon
juice or melon juice to push the fluid out that
will work but it's usually temporary so you just
have to start including vegetables in the diet
for the potassium the enzymes and also just to
heal the organs quality protein you don't want
to do if you have swelling in ankles don't be
doing like protein powders you want to do like
high quality from the health food store grass
fed either beef or fish or seafood you want
to do a high quality protein okay not a fast
food you know burger that's not going to work
you're going to have to get the sugar out for
sure that's a given I'm not even saying that
because I'm assuming you already know that but
you cannot have sugar around this at all because
sugars is going to cause swelling just on it and
itself now the other thing that's really powerful
is an enzyme called Serra pep taste okay you've
never heard about this you need to know about this
Serra pepper taste basically will dissolve scar
tissue it gets rid of fibrous unwanted tissue
it dissolves clots in the arteries and improve
circulation it helps inflammation it also will
help other cirrhosis on the liver see what happens
with the liver is it has an inflammation State and
in a develop scar tissue and most people with this
a demon in the feet have a bit of cirrhosis at
scar tissue in the liver this enzyme will help
to dissolve that so this enzyme comes from a
silkworm okay but I think they can now make it
they can ferment it and make it in a certain way I
don't know the whole mechanics but this is one of
the best solutions for fluid because it opens
up your circulation it helps repair the liver
especially the scar tissue and also the kidney
too so it just gets the circulation going for
you now can actually have a better protein and
to happen this is a very powerful enzyme for
proteins okay but it won't harm your own body's
proteins it only seems to go after the proteins
that shouldn't be there so that's good for so
many things so anyway that's what I'm going to
recommend if you have this and I would get it's
a little pricey to get something but I would get
something like get 120 international 120 thousand
international units or maybe even you can find at
250 thousand I use of this enzyme and take
it several times a day on an empty stomach
if you take it with food it won't work okay so
it goes into the blood and starts cleaning and
that's a real good way to correct a liver but
the reason I talked about this last is that I
want you to correct the diet first so you're not
just dependent on some pill magical pill that's
going to heal everything you have to fix it up
but this is just going to enhance everything
and really get you in good shape alright
thanks for watching put your comments below